quand on accepte de devenir un membre du
gouvernement il est impératif de passer
par une case qui n'est pas toujours très
agréables celle de la déclaration de
patrimoine
je n'aime pas la transparence je n'aime
pas la transperce ans c'est le cas de
l'avocat eric dupond-moretti aujourd'hui
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
en plus d'un confortable salaire de
70000 euros par mois pour ses qualité
d'avocat eric dupond-moretti possède un
patrimoine immobilier impressionnant une
maison de 300 m² à nice acheté 1,5
million d'euros
un appartement de 200 m² à paris qu'il a
acheté 1,8 million d'euros en 2010 et
qui est aujourd'hui estimé à près de
trois millions d'euros une autre maison
dans les hauts de france et un autre
appartement à paris
plus une autre maison de vacances en
italie mais ce n'est pas tout car en
plus de bien dormir eric dupond moretti
a de quoi se déplacer et comme il faut
motos voitures on retrouve dans son
garage une bentley à 80000 euros
une harley davidson à 24000 euros ou
encore un bateau d'une valeur de 30
mille euros une petite fortune que
l'avocat a amassé notamment grâce au
succès de ses livres et de ses pièces de
théâtre à leur rolex bentley immobilier
êtes vous choqué par la déclaration de
patrimoine d'eric dupond-moretti
non mais alors tout le monde n'a pas
réagi sur lorient a pâti c'est énorme et
ça fait 40 ans qui travaille si les
avocats les plus brillants france jespo
tant mieux pour lui qu'il n'a pas très
bien aux rumeurs qui est patrimoine
franchement connaissance de cause au
gouverneur et savait que ça allait à des
plus grands avocats ont déclaré
fictivement tous que tout ce qu on a
évidemment de la déclarer évidemment
fait des commentaires mais en france et
à son président c'est normal parce que
c'était vachement bien
c'est c'est de déclarer son patrimoine
avait c'était avant ce n'est pas le cas
les impôts légèrement il faisait des
abus de biens sociaux sa passagère
demande est ce que les chroniqueurs
déclare le patrimoine également ses
biens a diminué roque c'est sûr
quand ils sont petits parce qu'ils
bossent lui depuis quatre premières
acquittement il rentre en 84 avocat et
depuis 87 ibos donc s'il a tout ça tant
mieux moi ce qui me dérange c'est quand
les hommes politiques qu'ils rendaient
pas beaucoup p
on touche 4 5000 euros de députés mais
il peut y laisser un avocat allemand tu
peux payer les insectes site a fait
toute ta vie un homme politique c'est
génial qu'à un moment donné tu as triché
jusqu'à 4000 euros par mois tu vas te
retrouver
je viens tous les jours des véreux il
vient du maïs que c'est l'argent des
gens heureux dans la polyvalence et oui
mais savez c'est pourquoi tu pourras
toujours ça pourquoi tuer pour toujours
parce que les politiques d donc on
pourrait aussi sur d autres qui ont soit
volé non parce qu'en tentant un
politique qui te dis moi j'ai fait
politique toute ma vie depuis 18 ans
jusqu'à ses 50 ans et tu te dis toute sa
vie l'a touché parce qu'il arrive au
monde
il a touché trop 4000 euros par mois
toute sa vie et après que déclare trois
maisons un bateau une maison dans le sud
est mais vous voulez danser un avocat
pénaliste radio là c'est pas ma
sincérité sur pascal je m'interroge pour
ça en revanche sur dupond moretti qui
vient du privé qui a fait sa richesse
tout seul grâce à son travail là dessus
ça me dérange pas alors je fais liste il
travaille depuis l'âge de 14 ans il est
là dit il a rien volé à personne on
parle de lui
alors moi je le sais j'ai un truc je le
dis sur dupond-moretti moi on m'a fait
une petite révélation jeudi il a déjà
volé un truc paraît-il qu'il aurait volé
l'orangé avec michel avec une fiat de la
star oui non par contre ce que ce que je
compte pour les gens c'est qu'on parle
de deux montres de bateaux et c'est là
c'est le connais un peu bling bling qui
peuvent choquer n'agissait pas ici ils
s'achètent ce qu'il veut celui qui veut
réagir gentiment et fraternellement
bonsoir alors vous savez qualité de
ministre matin et touche que 8500 euros
c'est que l'amour est que non mais par
rapport aux 70 milles annoncé tout à
l'heure
bien sûr et à savoir en revanche vous
avez qui modulent ses honoraires
selon le client par exemple je crois qu
balkany il leur a demandé jusqu'à deux
cent mille euros pour leur défense
datant du coup c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
arrêté d'être défendu par lui en
revanche il peut prendre des toutes
petites sommes bien sûr plus c'est un
autre sujet oui mais j'ai un style à la
prose on ira du côté du cirque ce qu'ils
ont donné leur patrimoine et prier quand
même ça oblige à faire par exemple de
regarder belge faisait savoir c'est
josiane françois hollande au regard des
parents aux lésés il ya par exemple le
voilà alors yaki bon je les ai pas
julien de normandie qui a une maison en
normandie
il ya bruno le maire et mary mary la
zone bachelot cas ubac jean michel
blanquer un bang
bon ben voila merci c'est les plumes est
au numéro 1 eric dupond-moretti de mai
de jean michel blanquer
roselyne bachelot bah oui parce qu il a
beaucoup travaillé à la téloche savez ce
que ça regarde et bernard montiel à 25
ans tf1 vous dire ils sont achètent des
vestiges et julien de normandie voilà
qui vient justement qui vient de la
sarthe moi je laisserais insupportable
cette manie comme celle de devoir
dévoiler son patrimoine qu'est ce que ça
peut nous [ __ ] partout de savoir qu'un
tel un bateau intel à une main je suis
là fait dire qu on puisse en plus si un
sous-entendu quand même eu à regarder il
a une montre garder une voiture ça veut
dire quoi maintenant qu'il est ministre
il doit se cacher il doit rendre ses
voitures cet acte insensé d'accessits
transparent chamakh isabelle qui sont
obligés de le donner aux institutions
chargées de les surveiller seront c'est
parfaitement normal ce qui est anormal
c'est qu'ils sont obligés de nous le
dira nous oui voilà ce n'est pas ça du
tout apprécié allemand le truc la
déclaration de patrimoine des ministres
vise légitimement à savoir s'ils se sont
enrichis durant l'exercice de leurs
fonctions